[Música]
piensa en el peor momento que has vivido
el más doloroso el más íntimo imagina
que después de pensarlo bastante decides
contarle esta parte de ti este fragmento
de tu vida que es tan complicado a una
persona muy querida para ti que no sabía
de este suceso y que reunirte todo este
valor para hablar de ello solamente para
escucharle decir que lo que te pasó no
fue tan grave que estás exagerando o
peor aún que seguramente fue tu culpa
que tú te lo buscaste desgraciadamente
esto es a lo que se exponen muchas de
las mujeres en el país que deciden
denunciar los actos de violencia sexual
que han vivido
en los últimos años y cada vez con mayor
frecuencia nos hemos encontrado con una
serie de mujeres que deciden denunciar
la el abuso y la agresión sexual que
vivieron hace años y el comentario que
más he escuchado que más he leído
respecto a estos casos es el de y si se
supone que es cierto porque no denunció
antes en muchos casos es una pregunta
genuinamente bien intencionada
la gente quiere entender porque lo
lógico sería que denunciarán
inmediatamente es más en una de mis
tantas discusiones con desconocidos que
he tenido en twitter un chico me decía
es que cómo es posible que se tarden
tanto en denunciar un crimen si alguien
allana mi casa o se roba mi carro yo voy
y denuncio inmediatamente
querido desconocido que me encontré en
las redes sociales déjame informarte que
desgraciadamente es un poquito más
complicado que eso actualmente me
encuentro estudiando la maestría en
comunicación y cambio social y estoy
realizando una investigación en cuanto a
los factores que limitan o facilitan la
capacidad de denuncia de alumnas
universitarias que experimentan
violencia de género
no les voy a mentir cuando empecé mi
investigación para mí la ecuación era
tan sencilla como si la institución
tuviera una instancia de denuncia
confiable y protocolos contra la
violencia de género accesibles lo lógico
sería que las alumnas irían a denunciar
después cuando comencé mi investigación
me di cuenta que a pesar de las
deficiencias que pudiera tener la
institución en la que me encontraba
llevando a cabo una investigación a
diferencia de la gran mayoría de las
instituciones educativas de este país si
contaba con un protocolo si tenía una
instancia de denuncia y las alumnas aún
así no iban a denunciar
entonces mi segunda hipótesis fue que
tal vez el hecho de que las alumnas no
reconocieran lo que les estaba pasando
como violencia de género era lo que
dificultaba que ellas se acercaran a la
institución a contarles lo que les
estaba pasando
y aunque en muchos casos esta sí es la
razón por la que las alumnas no creen
necesario ir a denunciar cuando empecé a
entrevistar las me di cuenta que no era
la única habían alumnas bastante
conscientes de que lo que estaban
haciendo sus compañeros sus maestros sus
coordinadores no estaba bien que era
violencia de género entonces por qué no
denunciaban
la violencia sexual es complicada
verdaderamente lo es los agresores están
protegidos por un sistema que nos hace
creer a las mujeres que esta clase de
violencias son lo normal que al mismo
tiempo que es un tabú hablar sobre estas
cosas cuando lo hacemos nos encontramos
que un montón de mujeres ya les pasó nos
enteramos que a nuestra hermana a
nuestra prima a nuestra amiga ya le pasó
y que cuando lo contó no le creyeron
las mujeres no denuncian cuando no se
sienten acompañadas
las mujeres no denuncian cuando las
personas alrededor de ellas les dicen
que están exagerando o que están
mintiendo
si las personas cercanas a ti no te
creen quién te va a convencer de que en
una instancia llena de desconocidos lo
harán
y no estoy diciendo que cada acusación
de violencia sexual sea cierta las
denuncias falsas existen eso es un hecho
pero yo quisiera que nos preguntáramos
porque en un clima de violencia de
género latente de 11 feminicidios al día
de al menos alguna conocida que ha
vivido una experiencia de violencia
sexual porque con todo esto frente a
nosotros sigue siendo tan difícil
creerle a las víctimas
por qué
porque sigue siendo tan complicado
porque nuestra primera reacción sigue
siendo encontrar donde pudo haber tenido
la culpa ella
porque nos cuesta tanto trabajo hablar
de violencia sexual
y la cuestión es que se nos dificulta
porque la violencia sexual nos rodea las
historias de violencia contra las
mujeres están escritas en la mayoría de
las familias de nuestro país
se nos dificulta porque admitir que lo
que le pasó a esa mujer que se sentó
frente a su computadora a contar como un
amigo abusó sexualmente de ella era
violencia implicaría reconocer que la
historia parecida que te contó tu amiga
hace unos meses también era violencia es
más que esa experiencia medio rara que
viviste con un amigo al que le dijiste
que no querías estar con él pero que te
convenció mientras cerraba la puerta con
seguro también pudo haber sido violencia
admitir un caso de violencia sexual es
difícil porque implicaría tener que
reconocer la gran cantidad de casos que
nos rodean que como que sabemos que
están ahí pero al mismo tiempo
preferimos no creerle a la víctima y
esto no es de gratis y menos con los
medios de comunicación que tenemos con
los programas de chismes donde nos
encontramos a unos conductores que
quieren hablar de este tipo de casos
pero que dirigen todas sus preguntas a
la mujer que está contando su testimonio
esta no es una pose una postura neutral
esta no es una postura objetiva como nos
quieren hacer creer antes de que la
mujer siquiera termine de contar su
historia ya hay una horda de personas
que quieren saber la versión del agresor
es que hay que saber las dos partes
social yo no estoy dispuesto a terminar
de escuchar lo que ella quiere decir
pero como quiere que le crea que lo que
me dice en verdad pasó si no escucho la
versión del agresor
o tal vez si pasó pero seguramente fue
su culpa para que se expone para que
toma para que se viste así para que sale
de noche para que vive una vida pues
si en verdad se tratara de lo que
nosotras hacemos de cómo nos vestimos de
lo que tomamos entonces porque existen
casos de violaciones a niñas de 4 7 y 13
años que evidentemente no estaban
haciendo ninguna de estas cosas
violaciones ocurridas por miembros de
sus propias familias entonces por qué
seguimos problematizando el papel de la
víctima y no el de los agresores porque
sigue siendo más fácil justificar los a
ellos y no quisiera que se entendiera
esta cuestión como una cosa binaria de
las buenas y los malos y la que nunca ha
cometido un error y el que se está
equivocando no se trata de eso
se trata de lo que podemos hacer en este
momento para quebrar un sistema que
desfavorece a las mujeres que viven una
experiencia así y lo que podemos hacer
en este momento es acompañar lo que
podemos hacer en este momento es
escuchar lo que podemos hacer en este
momento es no apresurarnos a juzgar a
esa mujer que nos está contando una de
las partes más dolorosas de su vida
porque creen que se dan estas rachas de
denuncia donde después de que una mujer
rompe el silencio se levantan decenas a
contar testimonios similares no es
coincidencia tampoco es que se quieren
robar el foco las unas a las otras es
porque al menos por un momento ya no se
sienten solas saben que a alguien más le
pasó que alguien les va a creer aunque
sea una sola
es por eso que se dan esta clase de
denuncias es más hay casos completamente
detenidos que se reanudan aunque sea
institucionalmente a partir de que se
genera una denuncia pública escuelas que
sólo así escuchan a sus alumnas empresas
que sólo así piden a sus trabajadores
que han abusado sexualmente de sus
compañeras de trabajo y denunciar no
debe ser visto como el objetivo
universal para cada mujer que vive una
experiencia así pero si queremos que más
mujeres denuncien lo que tenemos que
hacer es asegurarnos que cada una de
ellas se encuentre acompañada por una
red de apoyo y cuando digo que la
denuncia no debe de ser vista como el
único objetivo para esta clase de
experiencia me refiero a que últimamente
hemos escogido ya no solo revictimizar a
las mujeres sino que ahora también les
hemos exigido que denuncien formalmente
como nuestro requisito para
no se les puede exigir a las mujeres que
denuncien formalmente y menos en un país
en el que se les asesina después de
pisar una fiscalía o un ministerio
público pedirle a las mujeres que
denuncien inmediatamente sin una red de
apoyo sin acompañamiento psicológico sin
un plan económico sin una estrategia de
contingencia no es exigirles cualquier
cosa les estamos pidiendo que se
enfrenten solas a la revictimización que
se enfrenten solas a un sistema que no
fue hecho para protegerlas y en algunas
ocasiones que se enfrenten nuevamente a
sus agresores la denuncia formal
efectivamente es una herramienta pero no
es una obligación los procesos de
acompañamiento psicológico institucional
o por parte de un ser querido no deben
ir dirigidos a forzar a la víctima a que
denuncie
deben ir orientados a la reparación del
daño denunciar en un ministerio público
no es la única forma de romper el
silencio no es la única forma de obtener
justicia y no es la única forma de
atravesar el proceso todo depende de que
necesita ella necesita terapia necesita
sentirse escuchada necesita volver a
sentir suyo su trabajo su escuela su
cuerpo quiere advertirles a otras
mujeres del peligro que representa su
agresor quiere hablar en redes sociales
sobre cómo se le ha negado el acceso a
la justicia
porque el proceso de denuncia formal es
un proceso sumamente burocrático que
exige muchas pruebas y que significa
volver a contar una historia sumamente
dolorosa una y otra y otra y otra vez
para que en algunos casos el agresor
siga quedando impune
es por eso que se dan movimientos como
el mito es por eso que se dan
movimientos como el yo si te creo
porque de esta manera ellas pueden
garantizar que se les está escuchando
yo sé que puede parecer que
a estas alturas mi consejo es que las
mujeres no denuncien y mi consejo no va
por ahí más bien se trata de entender
que la denuncia es un proceso sumamente
complicado y que no podemos exigirles a
las mujeres que lo hagan si a veces
nosotros ni siquiera sabemos en qué
consiste ese proceso si queremos que más
mujeres hablen
necesitamos garantizar necesitamos
ofrecer por parte nuestra este
acompañamiento
así que el día de hoy yo quisiera que se
preguntarán la próxima vez en lugar de
que se preguntarán por qué por qué no
denunció antes en lugar de eso se
preguntarán qué haría yo si una mujer
cercana a mí me dijera que le agredieron
sexualmente
la acompañaría con la juzgaría porque
como podemos exigirles a las mujeres que
denuncien si no estamos dispuestos a
acompañarlas
[Música]